thank you so much for staying to the end
of this conference it's been so great so
far and I'm really really happy to be
here I want to start by saying
disclaimer which a lot of people have
said in this conference - is that views
are my own and so let me tell you a
little bit about Who I am I used to work
for Doctors Without Borders for the past
six years doing communications and
advocacy so I was originally based in
the New York office I was running a
campaign getting Pfizer to lower the
price of a pneumonia vaccine and after
they lowered the price I switched over
to a field contract so I did a mission
in Kibera Kenya and then last summer and
beginning this year i was based in Miami
and I finished my mission earlier this
year so at Doctors Without Borders we
put out a lot of reports about public
health issues right and as a
communications manager my job is to tell
stories to get attention and get the
right kind of media attention around
these issues so I care a lot about how
our work is perceived because that has a
real impact on the populations that we
work in and our operations and I've
noticed these days that you know our
role is more and more polarized and I'm
not just talking about like the US
elections you know I I think the issue
really started with the birth of social
media right you know because of how
things get optimized on social media we
like headline news we like things in
photo format and we like small sound
bites right and over time that's really
changed our behavior it shrink our
attention span you know and it really
changes how we consume content and as a
result you know a lot of information
gets taken out of context and I think
that's why a lot of our news feels
really sensational and we feel really
divided as a human race so today I want
to talk about what considerations we
have to keep in mind when creating data
stories in this environment
and let me clarify like what I mean by
data storytelling you know so I'm not
here to talk about the ethics of data
science or how to put together a good
data analysis I'm just going to go ahead
and assume that everyone in this room
cares a lot about the integrity of your
data work right but what happens when
your analysis is done and you're ready
to you know publish it either as a
business report or go to the media or
it's just something that you push online
you know what happens to it then you
know what considerations do we have to
keep in mind and how do we essentially
you know protect the integrity of our
analysis when it's ready for the world
to see I think I want to start by giving
an example of that illustrates kind of
the challenge I were working in this is
an article that was published by the
Guardian earlier this year and the
headline says revealed Facebook hate
speech exploded in Myanmar during or
hinder crisis it's very dramatic
it's very sensational and reading the
headline alone gives the impression that
everyone amia MA is posting hateful
things about the range of population on
Facebook but if you read a couple of
paragraphs down to the article it gives
the source of the data and this study
pulled comments from one Facebook group
called the ma'buta and the mob athough
is a hard-line nationalist Buddhist
organization with a follow him around
55,000 people but other time this data
was pulled so that is inherently not
representative of the whole country and
really what this study found was that
hate speech exploded in a hard-line
national group during the reinsure
crisis and it's irresponsible to imply
that the views of this one group as
representative of the entire country
which has many ethnicities each with
their own identity and their values all
right so I reached out to the researcher
his name is Razer Otto because he
published a really well documented
github post that shows the data its
limitations and
his way of thinking when he was
processing this information and I
wondered how all that context got lost
in the published article and we talked
about how a lot of times this is just
out of the control of researchers and
even communications managers because
when we hand off our data analysis to
the media even with briefing even with
context we also hand over control of how
this story is told so one that's one of
the challenges that we have to deal with
is once your data story goes out into
the world it can grow and take on a life
of its own I also noticed another kind
of interesting response is that in the
US on social media there is so much
outrage over Facebook regarding this
article and I fundamentally believe in
holding tech companies accountable for
how their platforms are used to spread
hateful speech and I really really hope
that they invest more in their detection
technology but I wondered why we don't
have that same outrage towards YouTube
for how Isis uses our platform to spread
hateful ideology and Ray and I got to
talking and we acknowledge that the time
period when this article came out really
impacted people's perceptions this
article was published in April this year
and that was right at the height of the
Facebook Cambridge analytical scandal so
people were already outraged at Facebook
and this just gave them more evidence to
not trust Facebook so this is the next
challenge like we have to keep in mind
is that the news ecosystem has a way of
impacting the way impacts the way people
absorb our data right we are affected by
what we see and then use and that
affects how we respond to this kind of
information so what considerations do we
have to keep in mind to protect the
integrity of our data story the first
consideration is can my data be
misinterpreted and to help you assess
this in this question I will recommend
two filters the first is what I'll call
a meme fill
right so whether we like it or not the
world in which we live in optimizes
everything online for like quick
reactions and quick views right and I
remember publishing like a Facebook
campaign a couple years ago and when
you're sending up the ad it runs it
through this tool that tests calculates
the ratio between image and text and if
we have too much text we had to cut it
out and so it's optimized that
everything comes in to mean format right
can you imagine if instead of
calculating image to text Facebook built
a tool that validated truth instead
right so the idea of a mean filter is
breaking down your your data analysis
into little bite-sized chunks right and
imagine if one of those data points was
pulled out plucked out and became a
story on its own would it tell the same
story message as your entire report ok
so here's an example we published a
report on the right shot bringing down
barriers to affordable and adaptive
vaccines it is a hundred twenty four
pages of really good data but the thing
that made news and made headlines was
that it's 68 times more expensive to
vaccinating a child in 2014 compared to
2001 right and so you know essentially
that it's the same story message vaccine
prices are too high kids are not getting
vaccinated that passes right and if it
doesn't pass a meme filter then you have
to consider what other crucial
information that this has to be paired
with to give the overall picture so the
next filter I would pass this through is
a news filter right earlier I just gave
an example of how the news / impacts our
perception and so you can be really
strategic about this you can bring in
some communications professionals and we
can put together a media report for you
or you can be really technical you know
pull scrape some comments off a news
website and do some sentiment analysis
like what are people saying online you
know or you can just do a gut check and
log into social media and just kind of
see what people are saying online but
whatever way or however way you do it
just take time to get a pulse of what's
going on in the news so the next
consideration is how might this impact
the people involved and by people
involved I mean the people in your study
the people paying you to do the study
the people who are going to read your
study and any other kind of dynamics
that you could that could be impacted
and I think it's really easy to remember
this when you're working with
humanitarian data but it's equally
important to think of this when we're
working with data that seems you know
that is not too sensitive and I'll give
an example
so the Pew Research Center put our
report about Asian Americans that we are
very diverse and growing population was
great I love this story message but then
I noticed something that I couldn't
ignore
I identify as Taiwanese American and we
are not listed as one of the Asians in
the US right so I looked a little bit
further into the data and saw that here
we are in a footnote
Chinese includes those identifying as
Taiwanese right and so my whole
existence is kind of reduced down into a
footnote and what this tells me is that
you know I do not matter enough to be
included and this tells all the
marketers or researchers who look at
this study that it's okay to group in
this way and you bet that this impacts
my life every day to the point where
people you know whenever they asked
where are you from from California no no
where are you really from and I say my
friend was from Taiwan
their answer is usually oh do you mean
Thailand or oh so you mean Chinese right
and so now I have a stranger explaining
my identity to me and so I'm not going
to get into the politics of this because
that's not my point here you know but
the point that I'm trying to make and
what I really want to get across is that
you know all this data that we look out
all the insights we gather and the
modeling and forecasting you know what
makes big data big
and I think what makes big data big is
that fundamentally each of these data
points represents one human and it has a
potential to impact an individual and
that is a big responsibility
right so ultimately what we want to
really try to do is to be able to pull
out the human in our data right we we
heard earlier yesterday from Rogers talk
how how these tools have really
transformed the lives of you know
millions of people it has that potential
but he also mentioned that these tools
have their limitations right they also
oh they only answer kind of the broader
blunt questions and and not the more
subtle context so my suggestion of how
to deal with this dilemma is whenever
you can to try to interview and speak to
someone who is part of your study
population right every time I meet our
patients and they share their most
traumatic experiences with me you know
it is a privilege that I get to hear
their stories and it is my moral
responsibility to make sure I
communicate it in a way that is complete
with integrity right and you know we're
not alone and trying to like figure this
out you know I think about this stuff
all the time because it was my job to
write but we all have play a role and
you know how our data stories get told
and traditionally this is the flow of
telling data stories right it starts out
with the analyst you know you look at
the data once you get some insights you
pass it over to the advocacy folks you
know what kind of ask can we make what
kind of decisions can we be informed by
this and then once it's ready it gets
passed down to communications and say
we're ready for dissemination right and
I really want to encourage a different
kind of work flow you know one where
advocacy and communications are brought
in right at the beginning and we work
hand in hand and coordinated in the
design process of this analysis you know
this allows us to from the get-go get a
good you know scope of what are our
objectives and by each stage of the
development we can really keep in mind
that the
of data storytelling and ultimately it
makes this all drive drive butter right
you know we can really design an
experience that tells the story that you
want to tell and I will end by showing
one example my favorite thing that I've
done is you know turning a data point
into performance art so the the data
point was that you know 2,500 kids die
from pneumonia each day right but how do
you visualize that I can just tell you
that but 2500 like what does I what does
that feel like you know it feels like a
lot in some contexts it doesn't feel
like a lot in other contexts right so
what we chose to do was we bought 2500
flowers and we did a procession from
Grand Central Station in New York all
the way to five tzer's headquarters in
New York which is about two avenues a
walk and you know we had people hold
these flowers and March slowly and
silently in like this bustling New York
City by they walked all the way to the
headquarters and once we got to the
front doors there is a crib brand new
crib and we had people place flowers one
by one very slowly you know and the
impact is that when you're when you're
participating in this activity you know
you're walking with with these flowers
or ended up being around like 25 hours
per person you realize that each of
these flowers represents a baby who who
won't go home with their parents tonight
you know and that kind of impact really
like drives in the message for the
people experiencing it and and the final
kind of imagery was this like pristine
crib over filling with flowers you know
2500 flowers on the floor and also had
an impact home fire you know now they
had this like giant career that they had
to move indoors and it sparked a lot of
conversations you know in their office
and the next day we attended their
shareholder meeting and this
you reacted to this performance
you know this protest and as a result of
that you know we were able to have a
meeting with the CEO and months and
months and months later of negotiation
more campaigning they finally dropped
the price and as a result you know now
we can vaccinate kids in places that we
haven't been able to before you know now
we're using this vaccine to fascinate
refugee children in Syria you know so
when we work together and we you know
this might look really like abstract and
artsy but we really work together and
design the right kind of experience you
know it can make a really really big
impact you know so I really want to
encourage that we continue to have these
conversations right because you know I
brought up a lot of considerations that
won't always have answers but we have to
keep asking them because it'll push our
work and I will push the impact that we
want to deliver thank you
you